I mean it's it's a long-term issue and
problem but of course weather has a
massive impact on the game and I think
we've just been starting to give some
thought how technology and innovation
can can help to solve that problem and
there are some emerging projects
particularly around in the states that
are looking this particular area and I
guess it's a signal from us here at MCC
Annette Lords that we really ought to
think about how we can keep the game on
for the spectator and part of that will
be about protection from rain but some
of it will be around wickets and how you
use drop in pitches and out fields and a
whole range of different things so so
it's a long way off but an exciting
interesting time and it's up to people
that are leading the game to look at
some of these things and see how they
can be applied I mean this technology is
deployed in baseball has it affected the
outcome of games in the way that
potentially would do here if it affects
that you know prevents boulders from
being able to swing the ball properly
well I think there are lots of look
there are lots of technical issues to
consider and I don't think we're at that
particular stage obviously you've got to
maintain the integrity of the game that
is paramount for cricket spectators and
that's why Lords are such a special
place to come and watch cricket so you
can't be impacting negatively on it so
we've got to have a think about all of
these issues and how they affect cricket
but ultimately we want people to be able
to come and watch and if we can get
player more regularly for more people to
watch that's got to be good for cricket
now this is quite a significant moment
in the history of MCC because the
members have just voted through the
club's master plan they voted down the
property development proposals to build
flats at the nursery and what's the
progress going to be like over the next
few years well I think just reflecting
on on the outcome of an overwhelming
decision to support the club's master
plan it was a it was a bruising an
emotive debate I think which which
regardless of individual opinions
reflected the huge care and passion that
people have for the club but it's over I
think that decision has now been made so
it's now really up to us to get on and
deliver the club's master plan and that
process has really started on Monday
after last week's sgm so we're in the
process of starting to gear up think
about how we're going to run and deliver
the programs and we're going to start
with the Compton edge Ridge stance
behind us and that's really the sort of
big first phase project which we which
we're taking forward over the winter
with the intention of starting after
2019
of course 2019 is an enormous year here
we've got the ashes ICC Men's World Cup
and then we'll get on and do the
development program from there so it's
an exciting time but also a challenging
one as a new chief exec they're looking
forward to that but in terms of next
summer obviously we've got India and
Pakistan coming anyone coming to the
home of cricket next summer will not
noticeably see any real big changes in
from the ground asset it is no they
won't the ground is if it will
effectively be the same for next year
and then the real construction program
starts post 2019 and is the MCC master
plan deliverable even if Lords only host
one Test match per year I think the
straightforward answer is yes it is I
think the all the work that went into
the into the preparation of plans
factored in a ground development
scenario under under those conditions
but I have to say I'm very confident
that that that we will be able to create
a case that is compelling and that we'll
be able to move forward on a development
program with the securing of those major
matches in place